mike kendon tracks climate change in the
uk for the met office
he's just written a report revealing
that 2020 was the first year since
records began
to rank in the top 10 for heat rainfall
and sunshine in this country
what we are seeing is of deep concern
because
these extremes have a real impact on
people and businesses
but global warming knows no boundaries
and so the global picture
is increasingly alarming when we see
recent events
like this canada heat wave where we have
a temperature of 49.6 recorded
absolutely smashing previous records we
were watching this event
we found it really quite shocking as a
scientist i'm worried
looking at these observations um you
know i'm a dad
i worry about the future for my children
experts say he is right to be concerned
outlining today the scale of the
threat posed by the melting ice in the
arctic driving a vicious feedback loop
of rapid warming due to melting ice in
on greenland due to melting ice
elsewhere on the planet
raising sea levels globally we
are going to see southeast asia maybe a
hundred million maybe
300 million refugees because regions of
that world will be
under water too regularly under sea
water we are looking at a
situation in the near future that is
really
too too grim to to contemplate
as climate change drives more frequent
and severe
extreme weather around the world the
urgent warnings are piling up
so is the pressure on a crucial climate
change summit in glasgow later this year
known as cop26 glasgow is the last best
hope
to avoid the worst consequences and to
avoid the planet changing in ways that
are even hard to predict the effects of
climate change
are already here without an
unprecedented
coordinated international effort to
reduce emissions
worse is likely to come hannah thomas
peter sky news